the single most valuable skill set you
can have is getting other people to do
things for you because fundamentally if
you know how to do that then you can get
somebody else to do every other portion
of the business and they can build it on
your behalf and so in this video I'll
walk through an in-depth process of how
I think about managing people to get the
desired outcome on a consistent basis
and how to have some of the hardest
conversations you have to have and make
it feel easy so let me show you
something that I haven't done in any
other school days but I'll I'll walk you
through it so I just call this like my
Management
Diamond so fundamentally if you ask
someone to do something you want them to
do it if they're not doing it then comes
the problem solving right which is
what
how when
oops okay so if someone doesn't do what
you want them to do the first and
obvious reason they didn't know what you
wanted them to do and so you fix this
one communication this is by the way a
really good framework for having hard
conversations when someone's not doing a
good job so you say hey
Carly I wanted you to do this and you
haven't done it so I just want to figure
out what the reason was so we can solve
it or make it less likely to happen in
the future so I figured the first was
that you didn't know that I wanted you
to do that did you know that I wanted
you to do that if they say no I didn't
know then you're like great now you
know right now if they're like I did
know that you wanted me to do that then
you're like oh did you not know how to
do it which you solve with
training which we'll dovetail into the
whole teaching thing in a second but
okay yes I did know that you wanted me
to do it and I know how to do it but I
didn't know you wanted it by now or by
tomorrow and so I didn't have a deadline
here so we assign deadlines when we tell
people to do
things and that's just again to hold
them responsible now if someone knows
what you want them to do they know how
to do it and there's a deadline
associate and they still don't do it
then the question is do they need some
sort of incentive were they not
motivated to do it or was something
blocking them I could have the best chef
in the world who's the most motivated
know that I want to make an omelet knows
how to do it knows I want it in the next
five minutes he's like bro I don't have
eggs doesn't matter how much I do like
sometimes people don't have like we
actually had this issue with my editing
team was I was like why don't you all
edit in the building and they're
like the upload speed they're like my
upload speed at home is faster than here
and so it actually just takes me more
time and so we paid Google Fiber to
drill a hole into the wall and
here we are now they can up it's faster
here now right but it's fundamentally
like if there are blockers then it's
like okay well can I just solve whatever
that blocker is can I remove that
impediment and so walking through this
has helped me have a lot of hard
conversations with people and not make
them hard it's like there's five reasons
that you didn't do it you didn't know
what it was how to do it when I wanted
it you were't incentivize or something's
blocking you any of these sound familiar
and if there's more than one then you
got to fix more than one and often times
if you
delegate if you basically you hand
something off to somebody and it gets
worse after you hand it off it's because
you didn't delegate it advocated it you
just said here you go good
luck and so that's a very easy litmus
test if you hand it off and it gets
better or it's neutral then you actually
delegated it and so what happens is most
entrepreneurs just find a human being
that has a pulse say they have a meeting
like this and just say a lot of things
at them expect the person to have 100%
retention and know exactly what to do
when they want to do it how they want it
done with no blockages the person's not
aware of and then be done be like oh
yeah I already I told him once it's like
yeah once not in a written format in no
structured form like and then you're
just yelling at them on a zoom call and
then two weeks later you're surprised
that they're not doing as well as you
after having done it for years
you know what I mean so we we think
through this and this is how I think
through um trying to figure out um
employee issues so this one's fairly
straightforward I my opinion this one's
fairly straightforward the two hard ones
are these guys so from a training
perspective I'll give you I'll give you
an example I had to do recently with um
a teammate or an employee here um I'll
just give
a so let's say there's somebody on your
team who's a dick right you're like hey
Caroline you're being a
dick um the thing is is that stop being
a dick is actually a pretty terrible
directive and the reason is because they
don't know what they're doing because
they're dicks they're like you just want
me to not be me and you're like kind of
and so what we have to do is so I call
it bundling and un bundling terms and
this is fundamentally why I think my
content does better than most people's
is
that like you've heard me to find terms
it's like okay patience is figuring out
what to do in the meantime so if I told
someone be patient it doesn't mean
anything if I say be
charismatic how do I be charismatic it's
like okay I need you to have more uh
vocal ranges when you're talking I need
you to pause for emphasis I need you to
say people's name I need you to look
them in the eyes I need you to nod when
they're talking like these are a series
of activities that when someone does all
of them we bundle them together and say
this person's charismatic and so rather
than saying be charismatic say I need
you do these six
things or stop doing these six things
that you are
doing and by doing that then people will
stop describing you as a dick and so we
had um so a teammate who's really high
potential like really smart hardworking
did all that stuff but something started
happening and it started acting a little
bit dickish and we had four leaders in
my company have like sit down talks
which normally wouldn't do but the
person was really good at their job like
I don't really want to lose the
productivity and so I was the last stop
I was like it's me or you're out so we
got to figure something out here and
he'd already been given a lot of
instruction a lot of don't be a dick be
nicer things like that but that doesn't
help anyone change their behavior and so
fundamentally giving someone a frame of
what I want to have happen as a result
of this conversation helps fil or what
you're actually talking to them about
and so like me insulting them or making
them feel bad doesn't actually do
anything for increasing the likelihood
that they behave in a certain way most
of the time it's just Clarity just like
when you hop on the call and you tell
people to do this stuff immediately they
will not like you and if they don't like
you they'll complain more which makes it
more like you get fired you don't want
to get fired great so all you have to do
is not do that at the beginning of the
calls people stop describing you that
way he's like this is so eye opening I
didn't even know and there was like four
or five other items that I'd asked for
specific examples so that I could say
like stop doing these things and people
stop calling you a dick and within a
month people were people were like dude
he's completely turned around it's like
he just actually had Specific
Instructions and so most of us aren't
willing to do the hard work of saying
like what is this person doing or what
does this person need to do which is why
I'm a big fan of checklist because it's
like this is what you have to do when
you onboard someone like check your hair
make sure that there's not a bed in the
background like I'm like yeah you're
onboarding a customer and it's got like
you know a pink bunny poster behind you
and it's like that's probably not the
first impression I'm really looking for
right so it's like these are the
checklists that you go through it's like
first you greet them by name second you
look at the notes and you tell them
about the goal and then when you took a
recording of the onboarding call it's
like why does Sarah suck and Caroline's
great just say well Sarah here's the
checklist you did three there's 11 items
Sarah consistently or Caroline does you
know nine out of 11 and hers
consistently get higher scores now if
she if Sarah follows the checklist and
she does all 11 and her scores are way
below the other girls then it means the
checklist is wrong which means that's on
you not on her and so it means that
you're incomplete in terms of what
you're trying to train them on and so
sometimes it's useful to know that so if
both people do the checklist and they
objectively meet the things then there's
other things that you don't know about
and so
fundamentally soft skills and hard
skills are all just skills it's just
that soft skills people just have a
harder time teaching because it's
bundled language and I think that's why
so many people struggle teaching
them so in training the team to loop
back to your question I want to figure
out what the problem is with the person
so I can try and loop to these things if
it's a training issue I try and break it
down as much as I humanly can if it's a
motivation issue um it really comes down
to reinforcing stimuli so either people
do things that uh because they get stuff
that they like or they avoid things they
hate getting fired is usually a pretty
aversive stimulus so a lot of people
will do things to just not get fired so
it's fairly strong um but the best
performers do it do things because they
just like doing them like the best
employees the best teammates they just
work all the time because the actual
conditions of work are more reinforcing
than any boss can be right which is why
a lot of people like on my team for
example with like a lot of editors and
whatnot they just edit in their free
time they picked up editing because
editing itself is a reinforcing thing no
one call cold calls in their free time
oh yeah I just picked up cold calling on
the side yeah I just cold call like on
my days off just because I just like it
like no one says that uh but the thing
is is that sales and editing have very
fast feedback loops and so you can
immediately get off the call and get a
reward you immediately get you see an
edit and or you catch a moment and
there's there's this F A lot of feedback
loops that are really tight and good
other roles have slower and longer
feedback cycles and so as a manager you
have to basically artificially input
more feedback loops into longer project
timelines or jobs that require more
complex tasks
um that motivate people through
reinforcement and so a lot of people I
think in culture say oh someone did
something crazy and so what we do is we
say what happened that caused them to do
it
but we actually invert how Behavior
Works which is people do things because
of what happens after they do them not
because what happened
before and so that's like what happens
after you do stuff is the latency of
training and that's how you train people
and so anyways I I I ge out on human
behavior stuff a lot but um motivation
fundamentally comes from deprivation
which is what are you most deprived of
so if someone who's very deprived of
Praise which many people are giving
praise motivates them if someone gets
praise all the time praise might not
motivate them just depends on the person
and so this is figuring out what are the
reinforcing stimuli from someone's past
that's getting to know your employees
better so you can do the things that
motivate
them money by the way has been
conditioned as a universal uh reinforcer
we've learned at an early age that this
thing equals whatever we want so it's
just a generalized reinforcer but there
are more specific reinforc that you can
give to individual
people so yeah that's that's that and
then block you just unblock the thing if
you can afford it whatever the problem
is so um that's my little Manifesto on
management if that helped out okay cool
oh great Where do you um where do you
find like more information to better
understand these Concepts because we're
in a very in like human capital
intensive industry management is the the
big piece that's missing for like every
company and that's why so many people
fail where would I find like this in
more depth and in more volume so that I
can understand these Concepts better so
I've got a special CTA for you today uh
this exerpt was from a school day so
this is from the school winners who came
out they were the top 10 and they asked
me about managing team and so I answered
that question but if you don't have a
business then none of that matters and
so to start a business you can go to
school.com we run the school games it's
for people who are just getting started
in business and that's what that's for
if you already have a business and you
have a big team and you want to scale
your team we run workshops occasionally
at acquisition. at our headquarters here
in Vegas and so if you'd like to partake
in one of our workshops you can go there
and click the scale button and uh
hopefully we'll see you soon so most of
these Concepts were derived from the
ground up from just like rat studies
with Dr cashy Who Sam Sam knows my my
good buddy and so um I think most
people just do a lot of things and just
like see what happens like it's very
halfhazard I think almost no one knows
how to train period I feel I feel like
understanding human psychology like that
was always my found even ignore
psychology really I completely ignore it
I I would say that you talk a lot about
it like you probably never heard me say
the word psychology not the word
psychology but what you're maybe I'm
blanking it right so so to get no I
don't want to get too far into that
because I will go there but um so this
is this is like for everyone like if you
want to basically have your
ometer always turned on it's separating
out when people give reasons because
statements or just blank statements of
like the other day somebody was like
there's only three ways that you can you
know make a customer worth more and then
they and then they continue the sentence
I was like that's just false they just
started the statement that way and a lot
of people make statements that are just
false they have no idea what they're
saying and so we walk through a
framework when we're trying to basically
detect
which is logic evidence utility
which is what does this mean
how do you
know and then so
what so I'll give you an example so I
had um I had someone the other day say
I'm stressed because I'm lonely and I
was
like okay I was
like what does lonely mean to you it's a
bucketed term right it's a bundled
term he was like well I was like that on
Friday night you have known to text or
that people don't respond back to you or
like what what is the what what does
that mean to you because it's there's a
thing there's an activity that occurred
and then they described it they chunk it
up as loneliness but when you get two
steps below that of to like what
occurred what was the action that got
stunted or something that you wanted
that you didn't get then you can get a
lot more specific we're like okay so
then I say all right so that was the
lonely occurrence now have you been
stressed before when that wasn't
happening yes okay so then how do you
know that that thing has anything to do
with your stress they're completely
decoupled right it's like all right
and who cares you're stressed have you
been stressed when things are going well
yes have you been stressed when things
are not going well yes so in general
you're stressed when you're alive noted
what's your point right and so we like
breaking this down allows you to just be
less confused about what other people
say and so the reason I'm going here is
because most people are full of not
purposefully not maliciously they just
don't know any better and so they just
like paired out other things they talk
about pop psychology whatever and I for
the most part have just erased feelings
intentions beliefs all of these words
from my vocabulary in terms of what
influenc his behavior because I just
only focus on what can we observe
because if I were to say this guy is
really motivated I'd say how do you know
what does motivation mean to you I said
can you motivate me I was like Define
motivation and she just like stood there
and melted and I was like right so you
want me to answer a question that you
can't Define the word for so what's the
likely that you get what you want really
low and so the thing is is we ask
questions about stuff all the time we
can't Define which means maybe we need
to ask better questions or at least know
what the we're talking about and so
anyways I bring this up
because if you going back to the
motivation thing if I say this person's
really motivated you'd say how do you
know it's like well they do all the
stuff it's like great then forget about
concept or label of motivation and just
say this person does these things great
and so I don't care if you feel
motivated or not if you do these
activities people describe you that way
and if you do these activities when I
had the conversation with the the dick
in particular right I said I want to be
clear I don't care if you're a dick I
don't care if you hate everyone as long
as you behave this way doesn't matter to
me and so a lot of people spend all this
time trying to be like there's these
seven stages of awareness I'm like how
do you know
how do you know that what's your
evidence for that and so what like what
are the activities someone has to do
okay they have to see your ad great then
they have to interact with it in some
way they have to take an action so if
you go through the leads book I walk
through the lead stages in the book and
it's only based on the observable they
took a step then they give you their
information they give you means to
contact them then after you have means
to contact like you these are the things
that like no one can like fight me like
these are the things that have to occur
and so if you if you reason up from what
can I observe with with my eyes it makes
life a lot
easier even when you're talking to like
a spouse you're like okay I'm really
upset like okay what does that mean
right now how do you know you're upset
and so what what do you want me to do
about it and so then you say like when
you say this what do you want me to do
when you say like if someone says like
you should know it's like oh I'll play
that game I'm hungry either means you
would like me to go get you food you
would like us to go get food together it
could mean that you want space it could
mean you're in a bad mood I was like but
I won't take one Q for six behaviors
pick and then it makes things a lot
easier and so you can start training
real realistically like anyone in your
company to behave a certain way by just
saying when you say this what do you
want to have
happen and also when you're having the
conversation with staff or employees or
whatever like sometimes we in in the
moment like someone disrespects you you
want to like immediately insult them or
whatever right but you're like okay
well what do I want to have happen well
if I insult them they're going to be
more resistant to me in the future but I
need to have more influence over them
not less so me counter punishing to
prevent their their thing in the future
it's probably going to be
counterproductive and so what can I say
that increases the likelihood that what
I want to have happen happens and so
it's like taking a second step forward
and me back to think what's two the
second order of magnitude effect on
their behavior rather than what I feel
like doing in the moment um and so when
you're trying to look for okay how do I
manage people better or how do I train
people better most training is just not
chunk down far enough and so the people
who are successful in whatever your
education thing is come in more
qualified than other people like have
you ever had a student or a customer who
you're like this guy's going to win no
matter what right it's not you it's
because of them because they have a
history of skill they have a larger
skill set um that they bring to the
table and so fundamental
the people who are successful with your
program are lacking the things you teach
the people who are not successful lack
those things and other things and so to
have the most comprehensive training you
would have to start with here's how you
write words here's how you type here's
how the internet works of course you're
not going to do that because there's a
base assumption which is what qualifies
someone to be a customer of a certain
level of skills it also works the same
way with an employee there's certain
level of skills that are required to
work for this role and so if someone
does have a deficiency then the question
is what's the return on effort I think I
could teach someone who has Down
syndrome to be a neuros a neurosurgeon
well I could but somebody could right it
just might take 30 years it's probably
not worth it because for the same
resources we get 2,000 other
neurosurgeons who don't have Down
syndrome right and so if you think about
your customers that way it's like and
simply thinking about like take out
character traits take out beliefs
whatever it's just I need them to behave
this way that's it just break it down to
the activities and it makes a lot easier
and so fundamentally it's like I wish I
were more charismatic I wish more
patient I wish I were more confident if
you just debundled those things and just
say how do I break this down to the
smallest level and how do I just do
those activities it makes it a lot
easier and so usually when training does
not work it's because we made an
assumption of a skill set that they
didn't have and so the more advanced
someone is the vager the instruction can
be so I can say or Sam can say hey man
you think you just Market school I say
sure
that's it that's the directive it's not
like okay do you think you can make this
many pieces of content you think you
could run this many pieces of AD or like
whatever it is right and if I'm like hey
think you make an amazing product keep
making he's like sure like it's not like
do you think you'd have an activation
sequence an onboarding are we're going
to do these things I like I trust that
he's to do it because he has the skill
set you trust that I can do it because I
have the skill set and so fundamentally
the more skilled the person is the
bigger the instruction can
be and so if you have lowl people you
don't have a lot of room for vagueness
so you have to be more specifically your
instruction as people get higher and
higher up in your organization you can
be vager and vager with the instruction
because they have more
skills and so experts fundamentally just
have more ways to be rewarded within the
same
context like if you're really good at
editing video then you have many things
that reward you because you have more
skills if you're really bad at it
there's very few things that reward you
and so that's what Mastery development
is